[Music]
Camihime my happy to chai defan It's
nice to sleep Prisma yeah
Then well then shutter true heterogeneous sex juice
Dabi brain also stop Jack Spenny Baiden Omote sand dune Akko
yeah
Floor and a bar
Arnett's verbal battle Practical sheet
[Music]
car
when
wh
[music]
U.S. John,
don't go This voice,
medicine
You've been flexible up until now,
yeah
Yakov also came to visit Japan and play
me The
utopian egg that the two of us called
dare
Why didn't you answer the phone?
Say
goodbye, I'll put it together for pizza today. It's
Yuri Kazuki.
Victor shows up and I can't accept the reality
By the way, without surprise Golf is a living legend in the figure skating world
I thought you didn't care about me But
from today I'll be your coach
And at the Grand Prix Final
I'm going to win the championship What are you watching as a team
?
And then Yuri Kazuki from Japan saw a video of all of Victor's programs and
got a thunderous imagination and decided on a coach.
Victor chose the advantage
and came here.  I'm here for a long time I
'm leaving for Japan as Yuri's coach
[music]
Did you forget the promise of your dismissal?
As for now, I think it's impossible to come back once you're done Get used to
the coach of Yuri Kazuki in Japan I think a is the best, but it's different from coach run It's a ghost, what's up, I love
music  Ah
, I'm sure I want to eat Luan with just the armor
Hmm, as a coach, I want to know what Yuri's favorite food is first.
If I can't win, I wo
n't be able to feed you
Yuri, have you eaten this activity recently?
I have to get back to last year
's Grand Prix Final figure
that I blamed.  It's a
small and classical room,
isn't
there?  39
Uni
Tell me anything about you What kind of link do you think about everything
What is there in this town Is there
a girl you like
?
But I'm drinking and running away from the air It
's nothing I
'm afraid you're still approaching
Yuri Sleep with me There are still many things I know as Kawachi Yeah haha ​​I
've
always admired you so much I haven't even talked to you much until now It's
close  I'm too worried about being here, so
I'm jumping away
ah ah ah hello ah ah ah ah I'm a
husband and wife coming to Viktor Starting today I'm going to start coaching with an advantage Really April 10 j
me ah ah  It's okay to upload information The
three sisters who made it private today Are you serious?
A four-upper vector of time
Standing at the top of the world
Wanting to catch up with Vector, I've imitated it over and over
Oh
[music]
I'm watching a video of Boca's vector program that I skied the other day
Saying that Inaji Nation has sprung up
Togane Fukumoto
Ka2-chan can't go on the rink until she loses her body fat.
I
just wanted a reason to take a break. Please don't do that.
I used to fly around the world as a ballet dancer.When
I was a child, I spent more time in ballet classes than at home.I
started skating on the advice of Minako-sensei, and I always
came to support her.
Yuri likes Minako Do I have a girlfriend already?
Haha, but if I'm broke, I'm 2 years old, and I'm a
ninja mansion
.
den o Soy sauce with legs
I want to make a special program where Victor is here, right? I
'll take it.
Thank you.
Hmm, it's from a distance, but if I give you a picture, I'll match Yakov's
whereabouts.  Already 6 c 8 b
I'm not saying it's important.
[Music]
Rotate
ahCafé
Volan I heard that quadruple rotation is for body growth What if you
don't follow orders?
I was yelled at for doing the same thing a long time ago
You can win without quads It doesn't matter if you're strong, you can still win the
rest of the world
Peace hyung A program choreographed by Victor who won without a
lap Give me
a 4 a
world junior  If you win at
I'll give you the best senior debut
.  If you're wondering, the go
ahead Kids Zoo
me Listen, body fat I got it back to before I did last year's group liquor.
And I feel like I'm on the bed
Eh,
big Japanese tomoshi Anuyuri is complete
[Music]
That's alive
[Applause]
I was promised to be the first to choreograph,
you 6 Don't
even get the choreography  I didn't even think about it
1 year Q What are you going to do until you let me go to 4?
I don't know much about it Dave, so
you should ask him Vector is a kind of me, and I've come to the point of failure I'm going to be
my coach.
I've already started the choreography for next season,
but I've been thinking a lot
about it.  That's what I've noticed the most
I'm the same person who feels like I don't have imagination I
guess I'll be
taking a break next season Can you give me that program
Haha, Victor needs power
.
I'm sorry, my mother, I'm sorry
, I completely forgot But you knew I had that kind of personality, didn't you?
]
Okay, I've decided on my short program
song.  There are several different arrangements, and I was at a loss as to which one to use.
Of course, I'll think of a different program for each
.  If you lose, anything that the person who was just an eyeballer will say is dangerous
If that's the case, the name of the clinic you want to quit I love that kind of thing, I
thought,
I'll let this industry run out of step,
and I feel Japan's advantage ah
Unpacking  oha The year I
received my
letter of release Aizu won't be comfortable I'm going to
[ __ ] this house as much as possible
I
'm going to be in
my room  You're not asking for opinions,
hot springs are the best, bathing with other people is spring, isn't
it?  Well, it seems like
it's the day
,
Janta is Yurio.  Hahahaha That's right.It
's a story that the match is smaller than the match.If you
win the Grand Prix Final in your first senior entry,
you're a stern.How can you be proud in front of Victor?
I went, but at a time like this it's Minako-san
Ice Castle or Sickle?
If it weren't for Ice Castle's glaze, Yuri's strength would change at any time Yuri's strength is an
environment where you can practice without worrying about other people.
-
I've been practicing alone for a long time, and
I thought you really like skating.  I want you to chase me as much as I can gain an advantage
And I'm actually a very beautiful bucket, isn't it?
I was able to learn a lot of things.
I can't lose the game of love
And I'm aiming for the Grand Prix Final after
that I think I'll listen to the song first
[Music]
This song has two arrangements with different themes
About love Eros and Agape
You guys thought about love
I don't know how I feel when I hear this song.
]
[MUSIC]
8,
I'm going to go ahead with this song The
first song is about love, the arc
is about unconditional love, and this song is about love, about love as eros
[MUSIC]
The theme of this polar opposite song  The two of you will be able to get it The
distribution will be done by Coder Yuri Eros
Beauty is
rising and going to the
future
It's more of a book with no individuality, so more time and people are better.
You can say things like decide your own image yourself.
I don't have either of them, so both of us can do it without falling out
with my fans, right?  If you buy this guy, you'll definitely win, but if you
buy this guy, I'll have the piku training go back to Russia
And you'll get used to my course It's your own wish
Okay,
what will Yuri do?
[Music]
I want to buy a lot and eat a lot of activities, so I'm going to do eros I'll do my
best to cover erotic stuff
[music]
eme
I love that kind of thing
[music] yeah yeah
yeah
[music]
2 h
dee
yeah  yeah yeah
[music]
wear
tee
[music]
dee
m  e
[music]
ah ah ah [music] yeah yeah yeah trip yeah yeah yeah
whoever can satisfy me will definitely satisfy me
Excessive money, it's a Russian side
Next time on the 3rd run my head throws away the food and Eros will take me to the hot springs
Aisetta Nishiimae Happy
defan
Navy Naa Kotsutsu are you
then Marsh
[music]